Dany pourquoi tu rentres dans le noir tu
dormais je fais des supers économies
d'ampoules
ça fait deux mois que je dors plus
insomnie chronique
hypnose acupuncture ça marche pas tous
ces trucs c'est toujours debout tu as
passé une bonne journée
[Musique]
non ça va pas te mettre KO ça va juste
te donner l'impression que tout a le
goût de chou à part le
chaud
[Musique]
t'appeler toute la soirée il est clair
que vous êtes plus que ça
plonge dans un monde bien à elle je
connais absolument rien bonsoir J'ai
rien volé
[Musique]
E
je crois que tu te rends pas compte
parce que c'est de voir ton partenaire
qui reprend vie à la seconde où toi tu
vas dormir
[Musique]
pas du tout quoi faire on fait tous du
mieux qu'on peut il suffit qu'une
personne te voit tel que tu es qu'elle
te voit réellement
[Musique]
ce soir c'est le grand soir c'est un
premier rendez-vous quelques idées qui
pourraient l'aider à se sentir plus à
l'aise pourquoi tu mettrais pas un
cadenas sur ta braguette je pense que ça
la mettrai vraiment à l'aise pourquoi